our eyes they're very very directed we
look at what we are wanting to see our
ears are a little bit more
omnidirectional you can hear a sound and
it you know this year we'll hear a sound
that came from there whereas this I
won't see a sound that came from behind
you and and like oh kind of works the
same way it's not it doesn't have a lot
of directionality so when ligo is on the
air it actually gets collecting
gravitational radiation from almost all
directions it's got it's the most
sensitive to directions directly
overhead from the L but it has good
sensitivity and in other directions as
well the only direction it doesn't have
sensitivity in is right along the arms
so so telescope you actually have to
swivel it and point it to where you're
looking in the case of Lago you you
can't really point a four kilometre long
instruments but it does it does eight
points according to the rotation of the
earth but it doesn't matter terribly
much because it's also pretty
omnidirectional
you